una semana después de que la justicia de
cabo verde considerara constitucional la
extradición a eeuu de alexa el gobierno
de venezuela lo incluye entre sus
negociadores quiere informar a la
opinión pública
la decisión de incorporar al diplomático
venezolano
álex up como miembro pleno de esta
delegación del empresario colombo
venezolano fue detenido en junio de 2020
tras una orden de la interpol eeuu lo
solicita en extradición por presunto
lavado de activos y por supuestamente
ser un testaferro del presidente nicolás
maduro alexa tiene tiene más de 400 días
secuestrado en una cárcel en el
extranjero violándose toda la normativa
internacional del acuerdo de ginebra los
derechos humanos los derechos al debido
proceso
y ese inmisericorde castigo al que ha
sido sometido fue perpetrado
precisamente por estar cumpliendo
funciones de la que estamos hablando en
este momento en la mesa de negociación
en la capital de méxico
la delegación oficialista indicó que
comunicará su decisión a noruega como
facilitador del diálogo y a países bajos
y rusia las dos naciones acompañantes
[Música]
los diálogos entre el gobierno de
nicolás maduro y la oposición iniciaron
el pasado 13 de agosto en ciudad de
mexico se prevé que el próximo encuentro
entre las partes se produzca entre el 24
y el 27 de septiembre
hasta el momento no se conocen las
consecuencias de la decisión del
gobierno venezolano para el futuro de
saab o si podría afectar el rumbo de los
diálogos
[Aplausos]